se esperaba que hoy a media noche fuera
la fecha límite para que la Corte
Suprema se pronunciara respecto a esto
sin embargo se alarga después de que el
juez Samuel alito tomara la decisión de
darse más tiempo de que los nueve
magistrados seis de ellos conservadores
asuman más argumentos recojan más
información para dar una opinión acerca
de las restricciones que se empezaron a
plantear desde noviembre del año pasado
al uso de la píldora abortiva en Estados
Unidos concretamente lo que están
tratando de analizar más los nueve
jueces de la Corte Suprema de Justicia
son las restricciones de una corte de
apelaciones del circuito quinto de
Estados Unidos que aunque dejó en el pie
el uso de la píldora abortiva si dejo Si
puso estas restricciones restricciones
Como por ejemplo que no se pueda
seguir enviando por correo la mife
pristona restricciones como que no sean
sola que que no puedan ser otro personal
médico el que autorice o prescriba la
mefepistona a las mujeres y que solo se
pueda usar esta droga en en máximo siete
semanas de embarazo y no 10 semanas como
ya lo había avalado la fda la agencia
encargada de la aprobación de
medicamentos que precisamente los
demócratas en el congreso pues tuvieron
una rueda de prensa y le pidieron a a la
enfermedad de la Corte Suprema que
tuvieran cuenta los más de 20 años de
uso que esta píldora ya lleva en el
mercado hay que recordar que en Estados
Unidos son más de cinco millones de
mujeres las que han abortado con la
misopristona es decir más de la mitad de
los abortos en este país se hacen con
esta pintura